the next public hearing of the
bipartisan house select committee
investigating the January 6th attack on
the U.S Capitol is set for Monday
morning the committee conducted more
than 1 000 interviews it plans to shed
additional light on the planning and
execution of the deadly Insurrection the
committee's revelations are already
proving to be a heavy lift for the
victims of that day Scott McFarland is
in our Washington Bureau with the latest
Scott good morning hey Michelle good
morning this week's going to feature a
series of new hearings from this
committee investigating the U.S Capitol
attack they've collected 140 000 records
in addition to those 1 000 interviews
but yes it's also a challenge for the
victims too
as the January 6 committee showed 12
minutes of new angles of the horror from
that day and as a hero officer knocked
unconscious recounted the attack there
were officers on the ground they were
bleeding they were throwing up they were
you know they had
I mean I saw friends with blood all over
their faces some of the officers and
families of the victims wept in the
audience in the front row watching with
Sergeant aquilino Gunnell of Virginia
Gunnell fought a war in the U.S military
but he says he never saw brutality like
the kind he did January 6th they kept
saying we're not listening to you police
officers whatever you say to us don't
matter he's still not fully back on the
job still nursing injuries from the riot
he was foot shoulder and hand is it hard
to hear these things and see these
things played again
um sometimes certain certain
aspects of it like when
I fear for my life Capital officer Harry
Dunn who tells me he endured racial
epithets amid the mob says he sought
help for mental health needs in the
month since
and for the Congressional staff who
barricaded themselves behind locked
doors these hearings can be a challenge
to watch is it hard as somebody who was
hiding in a room for her life to watch
all that absolutely it you know that day
was agonizing it was excruciating did
you relive it watching those videos it
was shameful and yes watching those
videos brought up those feelings each
month now on Capitol Hill a group of
staffers privately meets political staff
police custodial and cafeteria workers
they need to talk about the trauma of
the attack on their offices from a mob
of hundreds some of whom were accused of
brandishing bats sticks pepper spray
carrying Confederate flags even erecting
a galley
Sharon Eliza Nichols a political aide
from Washington helped form the group
doesn't show up dozen showed up to our
first meeting we're expecting dozens to
show up again next week because the
hearings the hearing will bring up 17
months after The Siege and in the final
weeks of an unprecedented Congressional
investigation for the survivors the
grief and the trauma have no sure end
date
Scott what do we expect of the second
hearing on Monday yeah it's going to
happen in the morning not in prime time
let's start with that they're going to
focus on the claims of voter fraud the
committee is going to say it has through
its investigation evidence that the
Trump team knew those claims of voter
fraud were bogus and that they told the
former president that and that it lit
the flame Michelle and Dana that led to
all the other steps between November 3rd
and January 6th
Scott when do we think the hearings are
going to end and then how does it finish
it's going to take about two more weeks
but one Committee Member tells me Dana
They're Gonna Keep investigating and
interviewing after the public hearings
are done we expect a written report
maybe late summer early fall and then
they'll propose legislation to make some
fixes or some changes to prevent Another
recurrence January 6 2025.
all right Scott thank you